[Musique]
hubert est catastrophé celui qui a
acheté sa maison il y a dix ans menace
de poursuivre parce qu'il a découvert un
vice caché
l'acheteur exige qu hubert faye pour
réparer un problème dans les fondations
hubert crois que ce problème était déjà
présents avant qu'il soit 8 même
propriétaire alors il se déclare non
responsable
mais l'acheteur se tourner vers hubert
parce que c'est avec lui qu'il a un
contrat
un acheteur à un délai de trois ans pour
poursuivre son vendeur à compter de la
date de la découverte du vice caché
si hubert croit dur comme fer que le
problème devait exister avant qu'il soit
lui même propriétaire il peut envoyer
lui aussi une mise en demeure à son
propre vendeurs qui pourra aussi
poursuivre son propre vendeurs et ainsi
de suite
par contre ils devront trouver que le
vice caché existait vraiment avant
qu'ils achètent ce qui peut coûter cher
en expertise le fin mot de l'histoire
une maison peut être une montagne de
problèmes et mener à une cascade de
poursuites